a global problem affecting every
american who is shopping for a new car
it is a worldwide shortage of
semiconductors that's hammering the auto
industry
and auto workers 75 percent of
semiconductors are made in asia and in
cars these micro chips power things like
brakes airbags windshield wipers cars
are like rolling computers these days
general motors and ford are among the
u.s automakers that have faced big
production cuts because of this key
parts shortage
cbs sunday morning correspondent lee
cowan recently went to michigan to learn
more about how this tiny little chip is
upending lives
there's not a window in the place
and yet miller's ball in dearborn
michigan has always had a pretty good
view
of history how long has this place been
here uh it's been to be 81 years in
november 81 years probably one of the
longest running restaurants here in
dearborn it's kept grilling its
signature burgers through wars inflation
deflation stock and housing market
crashes
even covet
but when the global shortage of
semiconductors a tiny piece of
technology that henry ford could never
have imagined forced the nearby ford
plant to trim production of its f-150
trucks
dennis miller knew his business would
have to tap the brakes too how much of
your business is tied to the auto
industry you think
oh
i would guess probably 60 percent
you know it's pretty big i don't think
anybody around here is running three
shifts anymore like clockwork his bar
stools would prop up the tired and the
hungry line workers just getting off
their shift some of them still come but
most of his regulars are back home
pinching pennies i don't know what's
going to happen you know i just uh time
to tell and i don't think this is going
to get over for a while you don't think
i would no i would think this chip thing
is going to be another year before they
get things straightened around and start
getting cars out again wow
all around detroit brand new vehicles
sit sequestered waiting for some far
away chip to make them whole
sitting there means they're not sitting
here at car dealerships which means we
used to have 25 salesmen now now you're
half of that robert yuliano is a
salesman for chrysler in nearby south
field if you learn to adapt you know and
recognize the trends you can survive
still time was say 25 years ago when
semiconductors were homegrown
made right here in the u.s
now 75 percent of that manufacturing is
done in asia
as you might expect that's been a pretty
big topic of conversation at union halls
like this one for years if we don't
start paying attention to the supply
chain the global supply chain and start
bringing some of that work back to this
country we're all going to be we're all
going to be in the same boat soon mike
huerta is president of uaw local 602 in
lansing michigan most of his members
work up the road at this general motors
plant which had been churning out chevy
traverses and buick enclaves
but it's eerily quiet these days the
chip shortage has kept employees brian
stead and daniel hinton out of work
since the summer how much longer do you
think you guys can hold on
honestly i don't know
as long as i have to it's definitely
scary but what can you really do you
know besides just weight and it involves
decisions that people are making on the
other side of the globe that are going
to affect whether or not or if when we
go back to work so you have no input on
yeah absolutely not gm says workers will
be back the first week of october but
for how long
no one really knows we don't know what
amount of parts are going to come to us
we don't know how long they're going to
sustain being able to supply us so you
could be right back here in
six months again we could be right back
here in two weeks
company towns like lansing have always
been linked to the economic tides when
one boat rocks everyone else's does too
stephen farrell's restaurant tony m's
all right who had their baked spaghetti
is doing its best to keep its more i
used to have 39 employees i'm down to
19. and is that directly related to the
chips absolutely he says the bar is
almost always filled with someone who
either works at the gm plant supplies
the gm plant or supplies the suppliers
workers like vinnie polito know someone
in every link of that chain i have no
family to have concerns about but a lot
of my friends that i work with you know
they got family kids you know they got
bills they got doctor appointment
dentist appointment bread and butter
worries that have echoed through the
bars of michigan for generations
back at miller's bar the lunch rush is
over things are winding down
dennis miller surveys the landscape
wondering just what dinner will bring
it's like everything else you'll get
through it
it's just
you gotta grin and bear it
in the auto industry if the optimism
goes so does everything behind it take
care now have a good day guys
millers is a survivor not because it's
been lucky
but
like detroit itself
it works at surviving
every day
for cbs mornings i'm lee count in
detroit
this is this is a really big and painful
deal for auto workers it's also the
reason why new cars are very expensive
used cars are very expensive and the the
analysts are looking at this and saying
it's probably gonna last not just for a
few months but for a few years it's not
going to bounce back makes me very
nostalgic for the days when putting down
the window wasn't boop with a computer
it was right
you got to reach over get the one over
there i i don't miss that uh i don't
miss those days but i do
i do worry about when you see stories
like this it's just another example of
how covet has affected all of us in ways
that you don't even think about so it
starts there and then it trickles to the
restaurant then it trickles to
everything that you do in your life yeah
i like what he said you have to grin and
bear it but i think a lot of us are
tired of grinning and bearing it yeah i
spent four years in michigan and when i
moved to detroit i quickly realized how
the auto industry is the
common thread that is literally woven
into every part of the city and when one
thing goes down it has an impact on
everybody that lives in it but it also
speaks to what we need to do here in
states and manufacture the things that
we may need to keep our industries
booming um thoughts are with the people
out in detroit i love michigan that's
for sure